1835.
The American Frontier.
A beacon of hope in a world choked with blood
and smog.
Little did the hopeful citizens of a still
newly-independent United States know, the
evils of the old world had followed them here.
Sometimes it took the form of hate, of violence.
Of desperation and starvation.
But sometimes, pure evil wasn’t just some
abstract concept, existing in and around all
of us.
Sometimes, that evil - that pure cruelty,
malice, and greed - walks in the shape of
a man.
One such man was James Anderson, an unremarkable
name for a truly exceptional man.
Exceptional in the sense that if most human
beings aren’t willing to sell out all of
humanity for their own petty gain, James Anderson
is definitely the exception.
After all, it’s by his design that we have
SCP-001, the anomaly that set the SCP Foundation
- and our entire reality - down its current
path.
Of course, you know the deal with SCP-001.
Not one anomaly, but many.
A collective designation for a vast number
of entries, all of which spell beginnings
or ends for the SCP Foundation and sometimes
even our universe.
Scarlet Kings, Howling Black Moons, Ouroboros
Cycles, and Gate Guardians.
You’ve heard them all, and seen the files.
But unlike all the others, there is no file
for The Factory.
That’s because the full story only exists
in the mind of O5-1, one of the most powerful,
and arguably the oldest, member of the SCP
Foundation.
He’ll die before he ever commits the story
to paper.
Some memories are just too awful to record.
Their details and implications are too painful
to ever subject others to.
SCP-001 isn’t just about Anderson and his
atrocities, it’s about all the terrible
nightmares that unfolded afterward - and the
deal with the devil that O5-1 struck to lock
them away.
For now, at least.
But it all begins with James Anderson.
His family had become incredibly wealthy in
the Revolutionary War, and in the decades
since, his fortune had only multiplied, as
fortunes tend to do.
In the early 1800s, he began work on his beautiful
and horrific magnum opus: The Anderson Factory.
It would be the pinnacle of the Industrial
Revolution.
The manufacturing plant to end all manufacturing
plants.
Three stories tall and a mile wide.
Company towns had existed for a long time,
but this time, the factory itself was the
town.
It had everything a worker would ever need:
They would live, sleep, play, and most importantly
of all, work, in the same place.
They would never need to leave.
All their wants and needs, from cradle to
grave, would be met in The Anderson Factory,
and all that Mr. Anderson ever asked in return
was loyalty and service.
Was that really so much to ask from those
whom he gave everything?
It may sound like a horrifying form of indentured
servitude to us, but to the people in the
United States in the early 1830s, this kind
of security and stability was a godsend.
To many itinerant workers and unstable families
across the planes, James Anderson seemed like
a saint.
Little did they know, his plans for the factory,
and them, were anything but saintly.
Nobody knows exactly what type of dark magic
James Anderson devoted himself to.
Many have theorized as to whether it was Satan
he worshipped, ancient pagan deities, or something
older and more powerful than both.
In actuality, the only thing that James Anderson
really worshipped was himself, and the pursuit
of more material wealth and power over his
fellow man.
Any pacts he made with evil timeless gods
were just means to an end.
The Anderson Factory was a citadel to one
man’s cruelty and corruption, and every
element of the building’s design seemed
to reflect that.
Groups of eight were forced into rooms together
like battery-farmed chickens
to maximize cost-efficiency.
People worked day and night, in shifts of
three.
Machines always rumbled and roared and chewed.
When workers died in factory accidents and
their blood spilled on the ground, it seemed
to reveal arcane symbols
carved into the stonework.
These symbols were only visible when blood
flowed across them.
While people traveled hundreds of miles to
live and work at the Anderson Factory, they
had no idea that they were working towards
slavery, subjugation, and death under Anderson’s
iron will.
And, in some cases, fates much, much worse.
The factory remained in operation like this
for forty years, while Anderson himself enjoyed
a positive public reputation as a groundbreaking
industrialist.
How Anderson got away with his crimes for
so long is sadly a tale as old as time: The
factory made valuable products and an awful
lot of profit.
So, no matter how many rumors swirled about
inhumane practices or arcane rites going on
in the Anderson Factory, nothing was ever
done.
It was just too inconvenient to ever reckon
with the horrible truth underneath the productive
surface.
And it truly was productive.
The factory was so huge and filled with such
a multitude of enslaved workers, there wasn’t
anything they didn’t produce.
From textiles to technology, to crops and
meat.
The machines were always on.
The furnaces always burned.
Anderson himself seemed obsessed with two
things: Efficiency and misanthropy - the contempt
and hatred for humanity itself.
He believed his workers were lower than him,
they only existed as a means to his nightmarish
ends.
And if ever the workers became too injured
to work, well, that doesn’t mean that Anderson
wouldn’t still find ways to put them to
“good” use...
The lucky ones, starved and neglected, or
broken by the stress of work or the grinding
gears of the machines, were used as material
in the production of products.
Some were drained of blood, so that it could
be used in the forging of metal.
Others were ground up into meat slurry and
used to pad out the beef, making it go further.
People all across the country enjoying fine
Anderson-brand steaks had no idea they were
actually dining on human flesh the whole time.
But as we said, the ones who ended up being
cooked into steaks and hamburgers after death
were the lucky ones - because at least they
got to die.
The truly unlucky injured workers became the
subject of James Anderson’s horrific occult
experiments.
Using a mix of twisted science and black magic,
he turned men into abominations.
Powerful, terrifying monsters, stronger and
more deadly than any mortal man.
Anderson was building himself an anomalous
army.
But it wasn’t just monsters.
There were just as many so-called “normal”
humans helping him rule over the Anderson
Factory with an iron fist.
They were vicious sadists themselves, spurred
on by absolute loyalty to their immoral master.
It was only after the Civil War that someone
finally escaped the Anderson Factory and confirmed
that not only were the most horrific rumors
about the place true, but they didn’t even
come close to covering the totality of what
was going on there.
When President Grant heard the reports, he
was disgusted.
As far as he was concerned, the atrocities
of James Anderson should not be allowed to
go on a minute longer.
The directive was simple: Find the factory,
free its prisoners, and put James Anderson
to death for his crimes.
And thankfully, President Grant had the perfect
group of operatives for the job.
They were an elite unit of around 150 soldiers
who performed a number of dangerous missions
beyond enemy lines down South.
Espionage, assassination, psychological warfare.
But these missions weren’t just against
the Confederates.
Some of the enemies they faced down South
were things that could not be explained: The
strange, the frightening, the anomalous.
And the highest-ranking soldier in this unit
was a man who would one day become the legendary
O5-1.
He and his men made their long and treacherous
journey to the factory, a trip that would
change all of their lives forever.
When they reached their destination, they
first had to deal with Anderson’s security
force.
These were men whose cruelty and loyalty to
Anderson far outweighed their skill in combat.
While they may have felt powerful when tormenting
starving, injured factory workers, they were
quickly routed and slaughtered by O5-1 and
his team.
When they ventured inside the factory, they
were utterly appalled by what they saw.
The inhuman conditions faced by Anderson’s
thousands of victims drove
them into a bloodcurdling,
murderous rage.
Almost half of O5-1’s men were lost in the
battle against Anderson’s army of engineered
monsters, but in the end, they prevailed.
Nothing would stop them in their quest for
liberation and vengeance, on behalf of all
that this terrible place had tormented.
They fought their way to Anderson’s office,
where they found him cowering under his desk.
For a man as despicable as Anderson, only
a truly medieval execution would suffice.
O5-1 and his men hanged, drew, and quartered
Anderson over a period of two days.
The sadistic madman died laughing in the end,
saying that while they may kill him, his factory
will never die.
But the factory was no longer his.
In addition to the Factory’s horrors, O5-1
and his men also discovered its wonders - It
wasn’t just normal items and monsters that
The Factory produced.
They were also, thanks to some of Anderson’s
arcane deals, the world’s leading producer
of anomalous items: Skeletal horses that never
tire, shadow cloaks that can transport the
wearer to different dimensions, toy guns that
fire real bullets, even yo-yos that could
flay the skin from anyone they touched.
These were anomalous objects that could shift
the balance of global power.
Items that could give them an advantage against
the things that go bump in the night.
While others among them were greedy or fearful,
the inner circle of O5-1 were united in a
singular purpose: Using the anomalous they
can control to contain the anomalous that
they can’t.
This group took over the Factory, making it
Site Alpha, their first ever containment facility,
and came to be known as the O5 Council.
With funding that came from a mix of blackmail
and friends in high places, this organization
- a burgeoning SCP Foundation - grew more
and more powerful over the ensuing decades.
The tools they gained from the Factory were
pivotal in the continued success of their
mission, and as they discovered more anomalies,
they also put these anomalies to good use.
But in 1911, O5-1 and his new organization
came up against an enemy that even the Factory’s
tools couldn’t help them defeat: A warrior
race known as The Fae, so named because their
only weakness seemed to be a vulnerability
to iron.
But these beings were an order of magnitude
more powerful than humans, or the beasts they’d
once faced in Anderson’s factory.
The Fae handed them defeat after defeat.
But soon, humiliation became decimation, when
an army of the Fae led an assault on the Factory.
It was a day that only O5-1 remembered: The
Fae slaughtered everyone.
Every guard, every researcher, every member
of the O5 Council.
They swept through the factory like a plague
of locusts, leaving only death and destruction
in their wake.
Only O5-1 escaped and survived, and that’s
only because he ran.
As he fled from the Faery forces through the
halls of the Factory, he came upon a door
he’d never seen before.
A huge, golden door, covered in Aramaic script.
He fled inside, entering the very heart of
the factory.
Inside, he saw the floating dead body of James
Anderson, bathed in red light.
Now, he was little more than the mouthpiece
of the Factory itself - or rather, the great
and unknowable powers working behind it.
The Factory gave O5-1 an offer, just like
the offer it had given Anderson before: It
would give them the power to turn back time
and destroy the Fae, saving everyone that
they’d slain in the Factory.
But in exchange, all of them would forever
belong to the Factory.
And in a moment of weakness and fear, O5-1
took the deal.
The clock was turned back to before the battle.
This time, O5-1 and his compatriots - all
of whom except him had no idea what had happened
- had the horrific weapons required to slaughter
the Fae.
Weapons that nobody, mortal or otherwise,
could possess.
They repelled the invading force easily, but
knowing the horrors that came before, O5-1
refused to stop there.
With the power of the Foundation and the Factory
behind him, he hunted down and murdered every
last Faery - driving their species entirely
into extinction.
As far as O5-1 was concerned, it was them
or him.
But with the Fae utterly destroyed and the
Foundation’s superiority assured, a shadow
was laying over O5-1: He’d made a deal with
the Factory, and someday, it would want its
pound of flesh.
O5-1, rather than facing the consequences
of his actions, decided to run and hide.
He had the Factory decommissioned, and buried
under rubble, never to be used as an active
Foundation base again.
But just because they were done with the Factory
doesn’t mean that the Factory was done with
them.
One day, a toy gun appeared on O5-1’s desk.
A toy gun that fired real bullets, just like
the ones they found in the factory a century
before.
The factory was still waiting for its repayment.
With every anomalous item from the Factory
that the Foundation used, the terrible place
only grew in its power.
Since the resurgence, O5-1 has been sending
the Factory sacrifices - D-Classes, dead and
alive, as well as Agents and Researchers.
But as time goes on,
it seems that these sacrifices
aren’t satisfying the Factory anymore.
It wants more, more than O5-1 can ever stand
to give it.
And when O5-1 refuses to give, the Factory
will begin to take.
And what the Factory wants, sooner or later,
the Factory will get...
Now go check out “Children of SCP-001 The
Scarlet King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?”
and “SCP-001 The Ouroboros Cycle - The Full
Epic Story Explained” for more frightening
and fascinating takes on SCP-001!